as a teenager my first real fascination
with the ocean was just by riding waves
as you begin to spend a lot of time out
there waiting for waves you begin to
wonder what's beneath you in the
following years I moved to get a PhD in
biological oceanography I wanted to be
able to photograph the ocean in the same
way that the fish would be seeing it so
we began developing lights that would
mimic the exact spectra of the seawater
and we began putting filters in front of
the camera that are essentially similar
to the filters in the fish's eyes that
would enable them to see this hidden
universe of fluorescence there were so
many open questions that we began to
explore
we set out just looking for this one
fish and in the process we discovered 20
other we began thinking what about
sharks
in a way to me science is fiction
because sometimes it just seems unreal
looking at fluorescence looking at
bioluminescence it's just beautiful it's
artwork this new era of exploration is
not about conquering nature it's about
understanding appreciating and
documenting nature there's so many
species to be discovered there's so many
facets of life that we have yet to even
learn about this fluorescence is just
one example
the future of exploration is kind of
finding out more where humans fit among
all the other species
it is my hope that by documenting
different life forms and then sharing
that with people they'll feel more
connected to life they'll want to
protect it more